here with moore's the author of the
upcoming book beyond biden rebuilding
the america we love and boy it can't
happen fast enough fox news contributor
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich you know i'm watching the
infighting and then the civil war within
the democratic party if it wasn't so
serious i would enjoy the fight because
i you know democrats want to kill each
other scorpions in a brandy glass i'm
fine with that but the reality is this
is so dangerous so destructive on so
many different levels from inflation to
the high cost of energy
that it actually scares me and the
number is so high
well i mean it should scare you
this is an effort by
big government socialists to profoundly
change america even joe manchin has said
in the last 24 hours
he doesn't want to change america and
then he can he although he's a democrat
he said this bill is designed to
profoundly change america to create a
welfare dependency
and i i think it has stunned him as a
west virginian how far they've gone
uh i think the people need to realize
this is not an accident
these people are determined to take your
money to rebuild your country with them
in control and you see it right now in
the fight over vaccines
when you know school teachers are being
fired nurses are being fired policemen
are being fired um
do we really want more
big government bureaucracies
led by politicians totally out of touch
with reality and i think sean you're
exactly on target here everybody
watching tonight should call their
congressmen their senators and demand
that they stop these bills it looks
right now like senator cinema in arizona
and senator manchin are going to stop
the bill in the senate it looks right
now it may change but like the left-wing
democratic party is going to be an open
rebellion in the house before the end of
the week
if all of that comes together then these
bills will collapse of their own weight
we did a poll in a project we're doing
called the american majority project and
and can i just say only one out of every
six americans one out of six favors big
government socialism
okay so the new deal fdr lyndon
johnson's great society lofty ideas
i i can understand because it's been
tried in many countries many forms many
names socialism communism
redistributionism whatever
and it always ends the same way i put
this in my my last book that i wrote
before the election that is socialism's
history of failure and in the name of
false security the guarantee of
everything people are willing to give up
their freedom and i don't have to worry
about anything my government's going to
provide
now it sounds appealing you'll never
have any stress in your life but is
aren't these the same people that
promised that you would keep your doctor
plan and and save money and we millions
lost their doctors and plans and we all
pay 250 percent more aren't these the
same democrats that have destroyed our
public school system the same people
that can't keep their city safe and
secure
that don't believe in law and order you
know my question then therefore is based
on their horrific track record
why why does why are so many people
caught up in the false hope and promises
that everything is going to be free
we'll just steal it from the other guy
look i i don't think you can explain
what's happened to america
without looking at the news media
the effort by the elite media to not
cover everything that's going on to
protect joe biden to protect the
democrats you know
when you go out and you start looking
and you begin to realize first of all i
just want to say
the best country in the world by
definition is the united states for a
practical reason
where do people try to get in you see a
big crowd getting into russia you see a
big crowd getting into china now
people want to come here because up
until now we've avoided big government
socialism we've had freedom we've had
entrepreneurship we've created wealth
people are dramatically better off in
america and it's it's a strange thing
that the left wing of the democratic
party is committed to making us as sick
as a venezuela or zimbabwe or some of
the european countries
with systems that don't work
i mean you go out and you look and all
these big bureaucracies are hopelessly
incompetent they need to be much smaller
much more effective much better run and
why we would give them
with all of their failures this kind of
money i think tells you how
ideologically driven the big socialist
democrats are and virtually all of them
with the possible exception of mansion
and cinema virtually all of them
are committed to higher taxes bigger
government more control over your life
and this is a real fight i think over
the very nature of america and what kind
of country our children and
grandchildren going to live in
all right so let me let me ask you this
maybe i'm not giving
mansion and cinema enough credit
but 1.5 trillion on top of all of the
trillions we've already spent
okay that's the if you add the 1.2 to it
well that's 2.7 then you have the 600
billion you know now we're over 3
trillion night 2019 we only took we only
spent 4.4 this is on top of all the
covert money
i don't think it ever comes a time when
you get to pay that money back you were
the last person a speaker
to balance a budget and you did it by
managing the growth of government
remember medicare seven percent increase
every year for seven years and they were
screaming it was a cut even though
you're increasing it seven percent a
year just lowering the rate of increase
look
let me let me say first of all
if we had a republican memories i know
right republican president
yeah but i'm just saying if we had a if
we had a serious republican congress and
a serious republican president we'd be
back to a balanced budget in five to
seven years because there's so much
waste
so much incompetence in the current
bureaucracies you could you could get
rid of huge chunks and they would
actually work better not worse
uh there are 240 000 people in the
department of homeland security
that's inconceivable
uh you know
give you a good example on the border if
we went back to the trump model of the
border and allowed the border patrol to
actually do its job
we would dramatically cut the number of
people illegally coming into the united
states within 48 hours
so i'm an optimist not with the current
gang
because the current gang they want
illegal immigrants to come in and you'll
notice by the way in california and
vermont they're starting to allow
illegal immigrants to vote
now that tells you part of the
democratic party's model they can't win
with regular americans they sure can't
win with people who come here legally
from these countries because almost
every person i meet who's come from a
foreign country legally will say to you
this is what i got away from i don't
want these guys to be in charge uh and i
think that uh we could fix it but we're
never going to fix it if the big
government socialists are in charge
yeah mr speaker great to have you back
thank you for your analysis as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else